I can't stand Hollywood I can't stand
vanity I can't - that's what I started
for right you wanted it I wanted it bad
until you saw it until I saw it and I
lived it yeah I I can't stand any of you
I can't stand the scene go back to
Jersey
it's up gone I want to go to Long Island
but my wife's like 9 Ireland we're gonna
make Jersey damn it damn it fine we'll
go to New Jersey and and that songs like
moth into the flame which is all about
pop culture
you sad but true was me constantly being
tempted by manager I knew his evil
mm-hmm and just always like you know you
should do this and taking your ID isn't
don't you want this all is it was they
meant something more than like oh this
is a great riff right totally now is it
so is that what you did is that do you
go like you're you're you're chasing
Fame SNL movies whatever it is and then
do you go you know what I gotta stop
chasing this carrot that everybody's
chasing and just start doing this stuff
that has a kid I would have freaked out
if I told you adult me would be doing
because it seems like you took that turn
like it definitely took that turn it's
not like metallic you you going on tour
with Metallica it's not like it's the
first time that something like that has
happened for you know like you've gotten
to associate with pretty much all your
heroes yeah which is crazy amazing it is
amazing
I remember being a kid on Jefferson
Avenue Long Island it was me and my
friend Phil I'm still best friends with
and gene and I remember saying I'm gonna
be a star I'm gonna work with Jack
Nicholson and Joe Pesci and De Niro and
I'm gonna be hanging out with the Mets
and my favorite bands in the world and
in my mind I think you know this summer
Jim Breuer sure or and like I'm landing
in my backyard and then there was a time
where even
I sit back and I go my god I did
everything I said I was gonna do I just
didn't do it the way I visualized it but
it did happen right and it's almost like
the world goes alright
are you satisfied yet right here it is
this is what you wanted right
alright well gave it to you now what are
you satisfied you need more like what's
gonna right and when it really started
hitting for me my first my first world
was uptown comedy club and that was more
of a real life's in their people support
each other was the Uptown cut was was
people say hey I was your big break the
break was Senate live but my life break
was uptown comedy club and then SNL I
just saw Hollywood at its at its peak
and bands I was like wow it really is
just a show this person you know the
Farley thing really I was I was really
taken back by that I saw that week of
him coming the host and what a mess he
was and I was I see I was told I could
not believe Mitch Hedberg everybody's
are the guys that you would look at and
be like wow that's what I'm going for
right well no I could not believe the
trouble they were in yeah and no one in
their team mmm
no one in their team took the time to go
when you're not you know working right
so what was more valuable your money
collecting from them or putting them in
the limelight or ratings or whatever and
that was really disturbing to me so
that's what kind of started to turn you
off Hollywood is when you saw like even
though these people have no business
performing they need help yes they're
getting milked for every dollar that
everybody can get out of and and I just
have people go yeah yeah it's gonna be
fine yeah that's gonna be fine and I'm
walking around S&S so and I always
thought to myself would would my friend
Phil would my brother they'd walk in
there and go hey [ __ ] all you right
she's coming with it and I know you
don't know [ __ ] get in the car
[ __ ] kidnapping dude
do you see what's going on with you yeah
and the fact that and it still happens
where I've seen in Mitch Hedberg I
watched him and I I remember going up to
him like hey man I remember calling his
people hey I would like to take this guy
out on tour man he's really good we go
I'm gonna get it for the valley reasons
but you can't see the problem he had
right new right hey you didn't you
didn't stop that you didn't but you're
just trying to get him on stage tomorrow
we'll figure out the rest of it though
just get him on stage that stage okay
here's a minute like that is to me
really dark and disturbing right one
more Jim and Sam catch up with full
episodes and interviews from celebrity
guests anytime on demand using the
SiriusXM app